don't let me down what is the coolest
new science thing you've learned to tell
me I've learned cool science things
every day and sometimes I have to be
removed I have to be reminded of them
maybe I knew them long ago like we all
knew that we have very a high common DNA
with chimpanzees like 99% identical and
it's ok I get that but do you know we
also have 50% common DNA with a banana
I do love bananas bananas there you go
and I got one others for you ready
if you look at the Tree of Life the
common ancestors between humans and
mushrooms split after what kind of
mushrooms after the common ancestor
between our common ancestor and green
plants which means we and mushrooms are
more genetically connected than either
of us are to green plants what I mean we
are like fungus and a fungus among us
relationships with mushrooms like be
around people you love I'm more likely
to learn a new fact in a science that's
not my specialty yes oh but I love out
of my specialty was science I'm just
totally lost do you have any questions
for Neil um do I have questions um yes
yes okay I've been thinking about this
backstage okay if an asteroid we're
coming to hit Earth yeah like how would
we stop it I mean this is possible right
oh yeah so we know exactly so there two
ways you could stop it one of them is
the macho way blow it up blow blow it up
blow the sucker out of this guy
although we now blow stuff up but we
don't know it's no way to where the
pieces go because they blow it up now
you can have two parts that are going to
hit or all the pieces what's gonna so a
kinder gentler way is you go up there
and you nudge it out of harm's way
if you get there early enough you nudge
it a little that accumulates and then it
misses Earth entirely that's a good
question so there ways you can do it
gravitationally remarkable a
gravitational tether so you have another
object and they attract each other and
so as they attract each other there's
not what with gravity
yeah gravity gravity feather gravity so
they attract each other but then this
this object you put up there has rockets
and it pulls aside and then they still
attract each other and it slowly drags
it out of harm's way there'll be a
gravitation like I'm gonna get all those
movies yeah yeah then you don't have yet
you don't get the flood New York and
stuff like know how to do it from an
engineering point but there is no funded
project in the world to actually make
that happen so we are just sitting ducks
oh my god we need you to become
engineers
[Applause]
cosmos cosmos you know you may begin in
1980 with Carl sake Carl Sagan yes
billions that practice my and I had the
honor his widow and co-creator and
co-writer and Riaan invited me to host a
revival of that in 2014 and then another
season coming out 2020 and so this is
the COG the continuation of this effort
to bring science to the public not in a
preachy way not in a sit down take your
medicine there's a science class pay
attention no in a way where you not only
learn but the science you absorb the
science in a way that matters to you
yeah where you were compelled to to
action where you say inspired it's
inspired wow I never knew that
and it affects this and our civilization
depends on it I'll teach you how to
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going